would you mean medical edition number 21
let's get started
me i'm still tired from all the crossfit
this morning my co-worker it's
pronounced croissant
and you hate four of them i wonder is it
is it quasa or croissant what do you
think of my french accent croissant
parlez-vous francais best pick-up line
ever dang girl you're my appendix
because i don't understand how you work
but this feeling in my stomach makes me
want to take you out
this is so weird i'm going to rewrite it
dang girl you are my appendix while most
people want to get rid of you because
they think you're unworthy i'm gonna
keep you because i've never had an
appendectomy
are you taking me to the hospital no
ma'am you need top medical experts we're
taking you to the comments section i
wish they said we're taking you to like
the meta offices because i feel like
that's where the best medical
information is these days doctor do you
exercise me oh yeah i do all of them the
push-ups plonks
doctor me crunchy doctor i'm gonna put
no me okay
you know it's funny i i hosted a class
where doctors exercise with their
patients and i was like okay we're gonna
do lunges lunch lunge and then i saw
some people getting hungry so i was like
not lunch lunch
dad joke head cold sore throat anything
else yes i'm a little hoarse ah you know
what's funny i wasn't gonna laugh at it
because it's really cheesy but the horse
is adorable exercise gives you energy
but you need energy to exercise sounds
like a pyramid scheme to me you know
it's a bigger pyramid scheme you want to
be motivated do something first then you
get the motivation you're supposed to be
motivated to do the action but in order
to get the motivation you need to do the
action first that's the ponzi scheme no
cure for heartbreak can't stop thinking
this is diarrhea did she leave because
of the diarrhea cause that'd be messed
up i too dabble in essential oils
essential oils i i hit home pretty hard
on but trans fats those are oils i can't
get behind stethoscope was invented in
1816 doctors before that doctors before
that actually use like one of these like
triangular cone looking things to listen
what's the wildest thing you ever did
for money is that school or squid games
i can't even
you don't need a parachute to go
skydiving you need a parachute to go
skydiving twice
[Music]
because the first time
i don't get it do you need a parachute
to jump out of an airplane no well yes
do you need one to jump out oh because
yeah to me need is equatable with life
so without life you can't need
misinformation that's some good news for
you when you say vasovagal syncope
instead of homie pooped so hard he
passed out how about this
neurocardiogenic syncope that's like the
next level of vasovagal syncope so what
happens when your body doesn't react
with its neurologic cardiologic system
fast enough to compress your arteries
inside your legs to increase the blood
pressure to supply more blood to the
brain when you poop so take it easy when
you poop falling off a roof when you're
a kid i don't know why they're saying
this because that could be lethal
sneezing too hard when you're
low back pain as an adult if you don't
warm up properly for a cough or a sneeze
it's possible to herniate a disc eating
five servings of fruit and vegetables a
day is part of a healthy diet don't eat
too many carbohydrates and limit sugar
intake okay i'm gonna explain this
spongebob mean because a warrant's
medical intervention by a
board-certified family medicine
physician when we say eat five servings
of fruit we're saying eat the fruit that
is within the sugar that is co-packaged
with by nature with fiber thereby
decreasing the absorption and the speed
of absorption of that sugar plus nature
was like we're gonna load it with
vitamins and minerals so that you're not
just getting sugar but you're also
healing your body and making it stronger
versus when you eat a lot of refined
carbohydrates white bread white pastas
you're not getting the nutrients you're
not getting the fiber you see the
difference thanks
yoga master jagermeister facts by the
way you know there's a condition called
saturday night palsy where if you fall
asleep drunk on a bench and you fall
asleep on the benches in here it
actually like damages the nerve here and
you lose sensation and sometimes motor
function of that hand if you're laughing
at these memes you're going to be
laughing at my show i'm going on tour
philly dc new jersey and boston click
down below to get your tickets now
they're selling out quick accu pasta i
don't know i would just want noodles
like
wet noodles all over my body
me when i wake up in the morning ripped
me after i have a sip of water this is
what it's like training for boxing and
i'll explain why i drink 64 ounces of
water when i box with electrolyte
tablets in them so you make sure to hold
on to that water and i don't know why my
stomach just go
how bad is your eyesight me
oh my god lately my eyesight's gotten
worse and i can't tell if it's because
i'm spending more time on my iphone and
i'm just like this all the time or is it
because i'm actively getting punched in
the head training for a boxing match
girls i wonder why we usually live
longer than boys boys top 10 organs to
sell to buy a gaming pc can't live
without all your organs you need your
organs in fact i'm going to make a video
of organs that you can live without name
one right now quick appendix no lung big
score found a ton of cotton candy hiding
in my attic oh don't eat that that will
like shred your insides god can we
report this video doctor waiting group
if you die whilst waiting to see the
doctor please cancel your appointment
that should be a sign actually for
the staff that is making the
appointments that if you see a patient
die cancel their appointment what
exercise to improve on this condition is
that a bathroom section that is pectus
excavatum genetic condition can actually
cause abnormalities of the heart but a
lot of people have very normal lives
i've actually seen a patient who had a
heart outside of her chest it's a known
chest deformity i believe detox teas are
p whoop and provax and will never vape
but real dr mike will never convince me
to not put q-tips in my ears i have very
little joy in my life don't take this
away from me but space hole what's blood
space
like i care about your tympanic membrane
what other person in your life has ever
came up to you miss c and told you that
they care about your tympanic membrane i
bet that's never happened before eating
is crazy you put food in a cavity where
you smash it with 32 bones then a meat
tentacle pushes it down a pool of acid
how about the fact that you take a sword
and you
slice a piece of cow and then jam it
into your mouth like we have many swords
in our homes having your nipples pierced
is a good idea until you think about the
fact that if you ever die you need to be
shocked by defibrillator the chances of
your nipples frying off are pretty high
you're welcome you know what's funny
i've shocked a lot of people with
defibrillators i don't know if any of
them ever had nipple rings and i wasn't
trying to save their lives i was trying
to bring them back to life it's
important distinction in acls protocol
when you zone out in class for two
seconds two plus two equals four rain
whoa
it's medical fun fact time have you ever
heard of an op abson seizure it's a type
of seizure where you actually like
become absent for a period of time and
then we put them on an eeg for 24 hours
that monitors their waves of their brain
and we can actually catch these absence
seizures and the fact that we call them
absence as opposed to absent seizures
was bewildering to me from day one
normal heartbeat deceased heartbeat when
your leg hair moves and it feels like
there's something
on your leg when you're jogging and you
wear like those nike tight or whatever
tight spandex pants and the little hairs
on your leg like form into like a little
knot and then you take a step and you
feel those hairs ripped i honestly feel
like that's worse than the torture that
you get when people put paper cuts in
between the webbings of your fingers
people makes medical memes and jokes dr
mike getting ready to explain that's how
i have fun what do you think doctors do
at parties we just like give medical
advice and make meme jokes improved pain
scale one it might be an itch two i just
need a band-aid three it's kind of
annoying four this is concerning but i
can still work five bees six lots of
bees seven i can't stop crying eight i
can't move it hurts so bad nine mauled
by a bear or ninjas ten unconscious this
is an improved pain scale but it leaves
out individuals who don't speak the
language i prefer the one with the faces
have you ever seen the one with the
faces
i flew a legit f-16 click here to check
that out as always stay happy and help
fighter jet you know the one with the
missiles well they took away the
missiles
[Music]
you